down a long bumpy track lies one of
unesco's newest sites
the yan primeval forest an indigenous
forest of beach fur
and spruce trees some stretching 50
meters high
protected locally since 1954 this
ecosystem is part of a sprawling
ancient woodland almost twelve thousand
years old
covering almost three hundred hectares
ecologist kirsten shtake has been
guarding the forest for years preserving
the landscape
and preventing man-made damage he
considers unesco's decision
recognition of his team's work
even in these turbulent times the park
administrators did not allow the
structure of the reserve to be disturbed
so that it
as such survived and became interesting
for further studies
this is the newest part of a growing
world heritage site without
borders last extended in 2017
to encompass 78 primeval beach forests
across a dozen countries
rare areas on the continent almost
unaltered by humans
however unesco status does not always
offer the protection it deserves
in poland protected trees under
continuous threat from illegal logging
in an area so vast it's almost
impossible to police
in yan forest scientists have discovered
an ecosystem almost
untouched rich in flora and
from fauna plant world we have the
protected plant species
lilium martagon from the animal world
also protected
squirrel and bears which are protected
from hunting
in the nearby town of chipovo there are
hopes the new forest
status will help attract more tourists
which numbered only 20 last year
we hope that this new unesco status will
be like opening a window to the world
to show off our natural treasure so that
we can reveal how nature regulates
itself
and solves certain challenges and
problems
one problem it is helping to solve is
climate change with the forest storing
millions of tons of carbon in the soil
and biomass
as unesco acts to preserve its future it
helps to preserve
ours charlie angela al jazeera